[Music]
[Music]
37
units we appear to be 6963 units short
if we intend to keep our ship peter
quill i know i know
we clearly need a plan what about
selling gamora's crap
what oh come on you've been hoarding
them stupid knickknacks ever since you
first joined us i mean
don't tell me they ain't worth nothing
quarantine zone was always
all the nowadays my figurines are not
knick-knacks
team's in trouble then you can't be
bothered to make no sense of course
i will sacrifice your head and take us
to the majestic mountains
guys i think we should
hear our group for once
you know the only problem with your plan
is that lady hellbender
only buys monsters and you are not a
monster
groot are you really offering to no no
he is not offering that okay it could
work
so groot i guess we could bust him out
after absurd
lady hellbender seeks the monster within
the small ugly one is clearly the
correct choice
he's cruel sadistic and his soul is
filthy and filled with rage
i vote we sell grew i honestly think
lady hellbender will go for it yeah well
i vote for not i also vote for the
creepy little beasts
two votes each peter
[Music]
well rocket's definitely scarier on the
inside he's unstable
and vicious and totally oblivious to the
needs of others
okay we uh we get it all right let's do
this let's go sell a monster
[Music]
we're not seriously flying into them you
say the weather patterns of secnarf9 are
tied to the temperament of this ruler
that's not how women work or whether
we're flying the wrong way yeah he's not
flying at all
guys relax just one minor
adjustment i ever mentioned how much i
hate brain
hellbender's castle isn't even that far
that is not a castle it is an
impregnable fortress
so how do we impregnate it ask peter
let's just get closer we'll figure it
out on the way
there is nothing to figure out as beast
merchants we will easily gain access to
lady hellbender
good we've already got a beast all
that's left is the merchant part good
thing i put on my official merchant
costume
there is no such thing
right the fact you ain't sure don't vote
so good
whoa that is some really crazy lightning
out there
never seen anything like it
meteorological suicide is what it is
out
hey is my jacket all right at least you
got a jacket
some of us are soaking here less whining
more
walking hey storm lord we ain't
seriously walking through this
it'll take forever in this storm stop
complaining
the hardship will strengthen your spirit
i face
more than enough hardship thank you very
much you are welcome
people one we got this just don't fall
and we'll be fine
everyone okay
you should have gone to machu 4
i would be wary you know what i survived
freaking half world i think i'm scared
of some little black
it's not alone get ready
what are these things they are amorphous
permit
shoot first questions later drop them
gamora
this won't hurt much
special off tracks meet your maker deal
boy is enjoying this way too much
this is the local fauna it's about to be
an endangered
species
oh you rocket time to go boom
i am eager to experience lady
hellbender's legendary menagerie
should we ask them for directions i'm
thinking maybe they are
directions oh like a signpost or
something
i'm not saying it's an arrow with the
word fortress on it but statues suggest
civilization and the only settlement i
saw when we were topside
was lady hellbender's fortress dead end
that's just great it's a retractable
bridge they used them at the prison i
was in
too bad the controls are on the other
side of the giant chasm
what do you not have time to dawdle in
this jungle i shall hurl the creature
over the chasm so he might activate the
breath i may
activate a hole through your face
put me down it'll be
fine just curl up in a ball what drax
throw him no very well
peter it's okay he'll land on his feet
ooh i i guess that only applies to cats
you sons are sharks scut-busting i am
not familiar with these words order the
beast to do its job [ __ ] it come on man
ram it fast fix the bridge and we'll
raise your cup by 5
i want 10. okay deal
thanks for the bridge rocket if you even
think
of pulling that scott again hear that oh
guys
i got it
these creatures are perfect
friend predators it together
is anything on this planet not trying to
kill us
guys huddle up
already missing the jiggle jelly
yeah i smell it too come on we got this
perhaps these were sent by ladies and
gentlemen regenerating
that is definitely my top 10 fortresses
peter aren't you forgetting something
oh right the cage
the point of even getting the flark and
thing was looking like you mean business
all right rocket time to put on your
monster face i only got one face quill
are you sure about this peter look at
him
you better have one hell of a sales
pitch
maybe gamora is right we should try
selling groot instead this is an affront
to democracy
i just think that we might need rocket
on the outside for this one
yeah we noticed
you want to make that call then you
better not mess this up
you hang tight there bud when the time
comes i'll get you out of there
rocket style if i gotta
don't look at me i ain't pulling that
thing
what are you doing
[Music]
who's the monster now
guardians of the galaxy
how many times do i have to kill you
the audacity that you
thought you could rob me
dweller feast upon them
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]